looks like the Senate Democrats are
going to live war during the debate over
Keebler Elf Jeff Sessions who was just
confirmed same guy
Susie wrong was just confirmed as
Attorney General today America's an
Elizabeth Warren ready thirty-year-old
letter by Coretta Scott King denouncing
sessions but apparently that is tort
yeah apparently that historical I know I
like how two people in the rest of my
life and I mean I could do this but
apparently that historical burn was too
hot for the Senate Republicans claims
she was imputing another senator and
silencer people like Betsy DeVos chimed
in with what does impugn me so Lauren
horn went outside read the letter live
on Facebook live right between a live
feed of a dudes trip to the DMV and
probably a video of a chinchilla licking
its balls Twitter immediately exploded
with the hashtags she persisted let Liz
speak and let Liz talk because they
support a woman's right to choose
everything except for one hashtag by the
way I don't know how they missed the
hashtag Liz Lemon party I would have
been great but you know I could see ya
because it's just you have to look at
what's happened she's interrupting a
roomful of old white guys jerking each
other off I mean it fit so perfectly and
thanks to all the publicity her facebook
life got over 7 million views instead of
the 7 it would have gotten uncie's
banned including her 3 grandkids now all
this started because elizabeth warren
would supposedly mean two sessions but
comedians she was all mean two sessions
but we're not bound by decorum here on
@midnight we're not on the Senate floor
so go ahead impute a politician anyone
Jen Kirkman okay Donald Trump is so dumb
that he called retired lieutenant at
3:00 in the morning because he didn't
know if the dollar was strong and then
when the guy was like that's not my area
he got mad and hung up but he actually
did that
[Applause]
take that up an inclusion Bernie Sanders
went as a scrotum for Halloween and no
makeup Paul Feig Mike Pence is gay all
right boys
[Applause]